[Music]
tom holland and zendaya's love is going
strong i just feel very lucky check out
the love birds enjoying a casual outing
in boston on sunday sightseeing shopping
and holding hands
that's tom rocking a lavender t-shirt
gray pants and sneakers while the 25
year old euphoria star keeps it cozy in
a cable knit turtleneck sweater gray
pants white sneakers and a brown fendi
crossbody bag
but really it was their love that was on
display that was definitely their cutest
accessory i am sweating the couple
cuddled up as they strolled through town
doing some luxury retail therapy hitting
up stores like rolex and cartier before
going public with their love in november
romance rumors swirled for years ever
since the first spider-man press tour in
2017. have you found that it's hard to
date hollywood so at such a young age of
course it is in fact at the time zendaya
dished on all that chatter to e.t i mean
it happens all the time and of course
you know we we expected it i mean it's
it's um
it comes with the territory it comes
with the job so it's all good and after
a couple of years of are they or aren't
they the romance rumors reignited when
paparazzi snapped the two kissing in a
car last summer
that was pictures of you and tom and
people were so excited because they're
like spider-man mj it's real like it was
like the world was rooting for this
moment the internet can be a cynical
place and it was overall joy it seemed
when those pictures came out well thank
you
and while neither tom nor zendaya
officially confirmed their love at the
time they did continue to spend time
together and praised each other in
interviews and on social media
the day i got to give you a belated
happy birthday very sweet post from tom
what was it like to see the post and i
noticed you commented calling now
no it's i mean i i am yeah i was it was
sweet i guess i don't know
um um yeah no i um i appreciated you
know the love that i got from my loved
ones and grateful for for all of that so
you know i have no complaints and after
going public with their love in an
interview with gq tom stopped mid-chat
with et to watch his girlfriend walk the
carpet at the no way home premiere in
december so how are you feeling about
that and tackling that they're losing
things i think zendaya
[Applause]
no no that's i want to see what she has
on can we watch is she going to walk
down here it's her let's watch oh she's
going in she's going in she's gone
and after years of playing coy about
their relationship zendaya told et last
week that she couldn't be happier to
have her man in her corner i think it's
great to have that support and that love
around you because you need that you
know this isn't an easy easy job so it's
good to have
that too to free you up from it every
now and then
[Music]
you